Kenny the six questions probably more in
your direction you're the head
commentator pfl Francis ingano all signs
are pointing that he's gonna sign with
you guys it's very possible I I don't
have the inside track on that I do know
okay I know I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't
break news right now I know that there
is some announcement planned soon I
don't know exactly when it's coming but
I've been asked this for the last couple
days I don't know for sure but I figured
we were in the running uh one of the
leading candidates I think it would be
huge for them bringing Francis over uh
would be massive so let's see if we can
pull it off man